on savait que dimanche il va y avoir un
changement d'horaire et oui mais oui ça
va être avancées d'une heure mais on m'a
dit ça alors l'heure on s'en fou pour
moi son énergie mt 12
[Musique]
un truc car il faut bien sûr les bus
publics mieux pis pour le faire on finit
plus vite l'eau pendant trois sets
contre personnes âgées oui quand on ira
chercher le terrain ou tard il faut une
heure plus tôt ça ne change rien pour
nous comment ça vous change rien parce
qu'on n'avait pas d'armes à chaleur
solaire doux c'est à dire à la vieille
on verra pas la différence si vous
voulez parce que les temps mr ou mme
asha alors de la marine l'almanach
seller de la marque qui compte c'est le
maire est ce que vous allez avancer
votre pendule dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi prochain
oui le faudra bien puisque voici cinq
ans six ans plus tôt c'était d'ailleurs
en janvier 79 ans bien avancé d'une
heure alors il faut continuer
sinon si on ne le fait pas qu'est ce
qu'il se passera il y aura trois sortes
de molène actuellement l'heure solaire
l'heure légale d'été et puis l'heure
légale du r pourtant on a coutume de
dire qu à molène tout le monde reste à
l'heure solaire
oui plus ou moins je crois il faut pas
trop se baser là dessus ce qui compte
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de confusion pour
la question des liaisons avec le
continent
le pêcheur liste vous allez par là son
métier veut qu'ils ne mangent pas à la
mange à toutes sortes d'heure alors
pourquoi que là-dessus il n'y a pas de
problème on est déjà gmt plus une
c'est sûrement fleurs d'une rencontre
gmt plus deux buts d'avancé pendant ces
deux heures vous êtes à gmt plus deux
maintenant comme les gens l'ont morte
changer d'heure ils vont prendre gmt
tout court et puis ça y est c'est ce que
d'autres et ça résoudra le problème il
ya pas de problème à 10 heures le matin
le soleil tafer midi ben nous pour nous
c'est me diplômant le soleil au milieu
de la journée
ça vous posera pas de problème du point
de vue administratif c'est plutôt mais
vous avez vous trouvé d'eiffage et avec
le continent
pourquoi déphasé avec le continent ne
vit pas sur le continent vit dans une
île
ça va pas vous poser des problèmes comme
ça d'avoir deux heures de retard par là
par rapport à l'heure du continent mais
nous n'aurons jamais deux heures de
retard si vous qui aurez toujours deux
heures d'avancé mais vous ne croyez pas
que vous aurez quand même 200 d'heure
c'est à dire leur administrative qui
sera l'heure légale
et puis aussi l'heure des particuliers
qui voudront rester laurie cholewa mais
au moins le long que deux sortes d'heure
sinon quand je vais vous dire il y
aurait trois sortes alors ceux qui
tiennent compte maintenant d'une heure
semble être calculé sont une heure en
retard si on est bien ils sont deux
heures en retard s'ils le veulent bien
nous sommes dans un coin nature et puis
on a bien l'intention d'y vivre avec le
mode de vie qu'on a choisie c'est-à-dire
leur chalet revoilà le soleil qui nous
dirige ici
enfin vous êtes restauratrice est ce que
ça va pas vous poser des problèmes avec
les gens qui vont venir cet été pour
manger quand ils vont arriver à 12h01 va
être que deezer chez vous c'est eux qui
viennent chez nous donc il faut bien
qu'ils s'adaptent à notre mode de vie
s'ils viennent ceux qui veulent venir
voir molène et ouessant molène tel qu'il
est vous ne pensez pas aller au devant
d'une petite guerre de leurs à molène
non je ne pense pas que ce soit toujours
que la même guerre qui dure depuis six
ans vous voyez que se portent pas trop
mal
petite guerre
[Musique]